hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven uncomfortable actions
that will make you more successful
number one is do that which you are
afraid of this is kind of the definition
of being uncomfortable right you put the
situation that you're afraid of doing
and too often what entrepreneurs do when
you have a big idea or when you know you
want to go out and do something is you
don't because you're afraid and the hard
part is you will justify it right you'll
come up with some practical reason why
you can't do it because you know you
don't have enough money you don't have
the resources or they're probably gonna
say no or whatever you justify it and
really the only reason is you're afraid
like deep down you're afraid but you've
convinced yourself because fear is not a
good thing right and so you've convinced
yourself that you know it's just not
practical for me to go and if you can
catch yourself telling yourself those
excuses and realize that it is just fear
and that you need to feel the fear and
do it anyway
and be as part of your routine when you
identify a fear that that then makes you
have to go through it like I have to go
and crush that fear I have to take
action that fear instead of being more
of a coward because of that is to rise
up and be stronger and take it on
there's a great t-shirt that I have I'm
gonna get my t-shirt where's that
t-shirt this is one my favorite t-shirts
so I keep it around this here says your
comfort zone and then where the magic
happens where most people are so living
inside their comfort zone and they never
accomplish what they want because
they're not stretching outside to go out
and get the magic and so if you want to
go out and do the magic you want to go
and accomplish your goals you want to do
big things you're going to have to do
that what you're afraid of
number two is push yourself to do better
once you identify what you're afraid of
it's now saying okay I'm gonna go and
take action and I see this a lot with
the people who have gone through my book
and I've identified there one word and
they look at their life and they realize
I'm doing a lot of things in my life
they're not congruent with my one word
congruent with how I should be living
and Gruen twith the life that will help
me get to where I want to go have the
impact that I want to have and be able
to touch people the way that I want to
touch people and so you need to push
yourself to want to go and do it because
it's scary because you look at that and
say I can't do that that's that's too
big a thing for me to do and I'd just
see it so many times the people who have
gone through that exercise and there are
some people who are ready there are some
people have had so much pain that the
pain of change is not as good as the
pain of the current situation where a
lot of people are just too comfortable
where they are and so you need to find
ways to push yourself regularly even if
it doesn't work out just to know so that
you're not living and regret you have an
idea that you want to try something you
want to go out and talk to this person
you want to know to have clarity to have
certainty on a daily regular basis I
watch videos of the famous entrepreneurs
i watch the top 10 series answer as a
series daily to try to push myself to be
better I look at videos I've talked
about this one with Elon Musk before
where he was talking about artificial
intelligence being the biggest threat to
humanity's and they asked him a question
about AI and how would have an impact
and he just sat there and said I don't
know and they asked another question he
said I don't know what dangers do you
see that you can actually do something
about I don't know can you really do
anything to stop it
I don't know well what should AI b is
for what's his best value you know and
here's this guy who's supposed to know
right like imagine if you were being
interviewed by the media or being asked
a question by anybody how often is your
answer I don't know usually you're
afraid of how you're going to be judged
and so you're gonna make up an answer
even it's not very good and I thought
about myself how often do I do that how
often you know what I have the courage
to go on national TV where millions of
people might be watching and it'll be
live forever on YouTube and somebody
asked me a question and I say I don't
know
and just watching him do that made me
want to be more courageous as well and
so you need to push yourself on a daily
basis to be better
number three is push others to be better
this is a bit of a tricky one because
some people are really receptive to
feedback and some people aren't and it
could also be a timing thing like a
phase in their life if they want to get
better and they need to help and they're
open and receptive and and others have
just locked into what they're doing I
think as an entrepreneur and really as a
human being you should be trying to have
an impact you kind of make people better
try to make the world better and to the
extent that you can encourage somebody
to go out and do something that they're
afraid of a lot of people and this is
this is sad but also rewarding you know
for a lot of people I'm the only one in
their life through my videos that gives
them positivity because everybody around
them is saying why they can't do it
given all the reasons why they suck and
they're never going to achieve success
and they watch a video on my channel and
they get inspired and they have a little
bit of hope a little bit of believed in
them and so recognize that you could be
that spark for somebody else you don't
want to be out there telling them what
to do you need to do this you need to
listen to me this is the only way to go
and accomplish something but to instill
some confidence in somebody if somebody
comes to you with an idea that they have
to say that's an interesting idea to try
to help them through the problem let's
just point out all the problems but help
them through it and give them
encouragement and give them some
self-confidence that could be a major
impact and it may be a easy conversation
to you but having one person believe in
you can make a huge difference could
save somebody's life and have a major
impact on where they go so try to
encourage others to be the best version
of themselves as well
number four is reach out to others it's
really hard to do anything significant
on your own you know you only have so
many hours of the day you only have so
much regionally have so much leverage
the people who've done the greatest
things that had the biggest impact in
the world they have done it with other
people whether they reach out to mentors
no they reach out to a team whether they
reach out to the audience they're
building something with other people and
it can be scary to reach out to others
if there's somebody that you want to
connect with over coffee not some
questions that can be scary if there's
somebody you're thinking about hiring
and asking to join you as a partner in
this business that can be scary because
anytime it revolves around including
somebody else there's the risk of
rejection and we don't want to be
rejected and again we'll come up with
reasons to justify why we shouldn't go
and do it there really is just that
you're afraid and so you have to think
about the people that you need to make
your vision a reality and how can you
reach out to them to ask her advice to
ask ask them to join your team to help
you get to where you need to go and try
to do that consistently and build a
muscle build that courage muscle so that
you're not just doing everything alone
for the rest of your life
number five is move on from the wrong
people you know you don't get to pick
the people in the early stages of your
life that are around you you don't get
to pick your parents you don't really
get to pick the people that you hang out
with wherever whatever school you go to
you know a lot of your life is dictated
for you when you're young but that
doesn't have to be the case when you get
older and a lot of people stick around
people that aren't great for them a lot
of people pick around friends and family
members or people they grew up with that
are not positive influences that just
make them feel bad all right a lot of
people stay in a job with a terrible
boss or terrible co-workers and instead
of blaming them instead of saying well
here's why my boss sucks or my
co-workers suck or my aunt Jonah
sucks right instead of blaming other
people it's on you like take
responsibility find a new job
stop hanging around those friends maybe
you don't go to Christmas dinner this
year right I mean it might be a tough
decision but you need to surround
yourself with the people who will you
know at worst just let you be who you
are and that the best support you to be
the best version of yourself and move on
from the people who bring you down
number six is public speaking in the
media one of the things that I believe
you have to do as an entrepreneur is get
your message out and it can be scary to
do that when it involves a camera right
if you're in front of a camera talking
or getting up on stage public speaking
is one of the biggest things that people
fear and again it's just one of those
things that you need to break out of as
you get experiences to get practice with
you know I was super nervous when I did
my first presentation it was three
people in the room right and then that
became easier and easier and easier I
just want to say summit and was speaking
to a room of 250 people and I'm used to
that and that's easier now you know if I
get in front of a audience of 50,000
people in stadium I might be a little
nervous the first time I go and do it
but then it'll get easier you need to
want to get your message out you want to
get not just your products and services
out but the positive change that you
stand for like the impact that you're
trying to have you need to reach people
and so part of that comes with talking
to the media and doing public speaking
and if you're so afraid of that that you
hold yourself back from doing it then it
will limit the impact that you and your
business can have
and number seven is stand up for what's
right
once you identify what you stand for you
know if you use the one word process or
something else when you see things that
are incongruent with it when you see a
world that doesn't live up to that
expectation it's on you to try to send
up to make it right there's an example
with China dance salsa our one word is
family and Alex is doing the operations
and running the business and part of
what family means to us is the global
family not just people coming to our
school and the people that we impact we
want them to feel like they're at home
on their family and they're welcome
they're accepted and they're validated
and we don't judge them but also the
greater community and giving back and
you know the countries are family in the
world is our family and trying to make
it a more family place right like
whatever year one word is you should
want to spread that like a virus to
everybody else to make the world a
better place and so there was a an event
that we held for relief victims in West
of Canada is a huge fire at Western
Canada and we did a dance-a-thon to
support them and to raise funds because
we felt like we needed to be an example
because we wanted to encourage other
people to do the same thing and so we
raised a thousand dollars for the
families out there now that's not you
know you're gonna have a insanely huge
impact but the media came out we told
our message and hopefully it inspires
other people to go out and want to do it
the same so if you see an injustice
against what you stand for or you see
something that's that's right you know
shine a light on that stand up for
what's right encourage the people who
are doing the things that you approve of
don't just you know applaud in silence
say that's great be more vocal stand up
for what's right send it for what you
believe in and you'll see not just a big
change in yourself as a human being but
the impact that you're gonna have on
this world so that's my take on the
seven uncomfortable actions that you
should take in order to become more
successful I'd love to know what you
think of a seven which one did you like
the best
which one resonates with you the most
did I miss one you want to add something
to the list leave it in the comments
below I will join in discussion thank
you guys so much for watching
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon